There were once three brothers...
...who were traveling along a lonely, winding road at twilight.
In time, the brothers reached a river too treacherous to pass.
But being learned in the magical arts,...
...the three brothers simply waved their wands and made a bridge.
Before they could cross, however, they found their path blocked by a hooded figure.
It was Death, and he felt cheated.
Cheated because travelers would normally drown in the river.
But Death was cunning.
He pretended to congratulate the three brothers on their magic,...
...and said that each had earned a prize for having been clever enough to evade him.
The oldest asked for a wand more powerful than any in existence.
So Death fashioned him one from an elder tree that stood nearby.
The second brother decided he wanted to humiliate Death even further,...
...and asked for the power to recall loved ones from the grave.
So Death plucked a stone from the river and offered it to him.
Finally, Death turned to the third brother.
A humble man, he asked for something that would allow him to go forth from that place...
...without being followed by Death.
And so it was that Death reluctantly handed over his own Cloak of Invisibility.